russia's foreign minister met diplomats
from several african countries in
ethiopia's capital addis ababa
it was his last stop on a tour of africa
where many countries have not joined the
west in condemning russia's invasion of
ukraine
but many of them are suffering from the
rise in food fuel and fertilizer prices
that followed the
situation in ukraine did effect
additionally negatively affect the
food food markets
but not because of of the russian
special operation
rather due to the
absolutely inadequate reaction of the
west
which announced sanctions
uh undermining the
availability of food on the markets
two days before lavrov was in uganda
ugandan president johari museveni has
courted both the west and russia for
decades including buying russian weapons
whenever issues come up
and some people want us to take
positions against russia
we say but you people these people have
been with us for the last 100 years
out on the streets ugandans are
struggling to pay for fuel
prices at the pump have nearly doubled
since the start of the year
and it's the same story for wheat flour
uganda imports it from both russia and
ukraine
inner magisha ibrahim sells omelets
rolled in chapatis which he's having to
make smaller because of the soaring
flower price even the customers they
have stopped off they no longer take
chapaties because they are small good
for them they want something that can
make their stomach
become okay lavrov's promised trade and
investment in the countries he's visited
he wanted to show that africa occupies
an increasingly important part of
russia's post-western foreign policy
so as the west has canceled russia as he
puts it the russians are looking towards
uh africa and other global south leaders
for power projection i think the trip is
also geared as showing that russia is a
reliable purveyor of grain to africa
even though they bombed the other
support right before lavrov's arrival
navrov defended the bombing of the port
when he was in republic of congo
the attack might be bad for russia's
grain deal with ukraine but it didn't
seem to put off any of the african
leaders who hosted him
malcolm webb al jazeera